my name is phillip and i'm a senior data
scientist at avidation health
uh and i've been working on building
data science products and i'd like to
share some learnings and best practices
with you all
so
in this talk i'll be walking through how
we're taking jupiter notebooks to
production in a real world application
of flu monitoring at scale with wearable
sensors
so with python libraries nbdev and
plumer
we developed a workflow that allows us
to produce maintainable robust and
production-ready machine learning
pipelines directly from jupiter
our new workflow made pipeline
development and maintenance easier and
more accessible
it cut development time of pipelines by
40
and it reduced debugging and maintenance
time by 60
so in this talk i'll provide a brief
background and overview of flu
monitoring at education health
i'll walk through some of the challenges
we face taking a research model and
creating a production pipeline
and finally i'll share how the mbdev and
plumer libraries really helped us
overcome these challenges
so first a quick background and overview
of flu monitoring at evidation health
our mission is to enable and empower
everyone to participate in better health
outcomes
built upon a foundation of user privacy
and control over permissioned health
data
evadations achievement platform measures
health in everyday life and enables
anyone to engage in groundbreaking
research and health programs
individual health has historically been
assessed using episodic visible to the
system data sets
but working directly with individuals
changes the way that we measure and
understand health disease and outcomes
so evadation is a two-sided platform
connecting enterprises and individuals
on the individual side
we have the achievement platform so this
is an app that you can download
on the app store
and then individuals can permission
their data for personalized insights
health programs or research
additionally they can connect wearable
devices such as
fitbit garmin and apple watch they can
answer surveys for points
and then these points can be redeemed or
donated
uh over on the enterprise side we
partner with leading healthcare
companies to understand health and
disease outside the clinic walls
with our achievement platform we enable
our members to participate in
groundbreaking health research
so for the past three flu seasons
evadation has deployed an opt-in flu
symptom experience monitoring program
so here's an overview of the in-app flow
where members are able to share their
flu symptoms directly in the achievement
app
using the permission survey responses
along with sensor data from wearables
like fitbit garmin and apple watch we
can train models for predicting flu
symptoms
so last flu season we adapted one of our
flu and kobit 19 detection research
models and deployed it within the
achievement app to provide daily flu
daily predictions of flu symptoms to our
members
we ran a small scale poc in production
with several thousand enrolled members
where we computed features from wearable
activity data
so this included
features around activity heart rate and
sleep
then we cast daily predictions with an
activity-based machine learning model
and finally we sent out notifications to
our achievement members
where the model had predicted positive
flu symptoms
so the poc was a big success overall but
there are a lot of headaches for the
data science team
and
yeah i want to walk through like
what are the
many challenges that we face when
productionizing machine learning
pipelines
from having to deal with
feature drift and data leakage to
latency requirements like there's a lot
going on
in this talk we're going to focus more
on the software dev and engineering side
of things
so data scientists love using jupiter
notebooks for the fast iteration and
development
but there are issues with using them in
prod
so there's two main options one is we
can use the notebooks in production
or the second option is we
take the
development notebooks and we translate
them to a non-notebook code base
if we go with option one
using the jupyter notebooks in
production
because they're stored in json they've
historically been a real pain to version
control and code review
this makes standard development
workflows cumbersome and the entire
development review process really gets
bogged down
using notebooks also encourage the use
of monolithic notebook files to run the
pipeline
these like mega files are really
difficult to update and iterate upon
testing and monitoring them is really
manual and slow
and debugging requires re-running the
whole pipeline file so even if it's just
a small
part of the pipeline that needs to be
debugged
um you have to rerun the whole thing and
this is really cumbersome and slows down
iteration
additionally trying to use notebooks in
production often ends up involving a
hybrid use of notebooks with python
modules where your notebooks are calling
to python utilities
so it's actually kind of hard to solely
use notebooks in production
so this brings us to option two
which is to translate the notebooks to a
non-notebook production code base
the issues with this are it's time
consuming and it adds complexity
high overhead to
adding testing and documentation
frameworks into your code base
means that
there's a high burden uh to integrating
them and
then tests and docs risk becoming an
afterthought
uh source code tests and docs often end
up living in different files so this
also increases maintenance costs makes
it more likely that these pieces will
quickly become out of sync
finally the translation process
increases the distance between
development and production
which increases the likelihood that the
model behavior in development won't
match production
so this brings us to plumer
we did a comparative analysis of open
source pipeline orchestration tools and
we picked plumer because
it's easy to get started with
easy and accessible for data scientists
across the orb to adopt
and it supports both python and r which
is great because we have both r and
python data scientists in our org we
wanted to enable everyone to adopt
workflow management
additionally polymer supports are
orchestrating and developing with
jupiter notebooks
so with plumer we're able to rapidly
iterate explore and develop directly
using jupiter notebooks
it enables modularization so we can
easily break the pipeline up into
separate tasks
and it really saves us a lot of time
with incremental builds so we can speed
up the debugging process
so diving into the first point uh
rapidly iterate explore and develop with
jupiter notebooks
so polymer uses jupytex to seamlessly
convert between
python and ipymb files
and this means that we can continue
working and developing with jupiter so
we're able to reduce conversion costs
it enables faster development and
iteration
and it allows us to create living log
files so these are executed notebooks
outputted from runs
where we can easily integrate docs
metrics plots
source code
anything that you could include in a
jupyter notebook
all into one accessible file
and this really makes developing and
debugging the pipeline much more
accessible for data scientists
uh plumer also stores source code for
tasks as python files uh which makes
things really easy for us to version
control and code review
and
uh it allows team members to use their
preferred ide so for certain development
tasks jupiter lab might be better to use
something like vs code might be better
for others
and this way you get the best of both
worlds
so the second piece is plumer enables
modularization uh so we can easily break
the pipeline up into separate tests
bloomer lets you set up and manage the
dag definition including the individual
tasks their products so these are the
outputs of the test and the various
parameters that you want to set
so there's no more need to hard code any
of this which is awesome
plumber also makes it easy to split up
the pipeline into small modular tasks so
you can now easily have multiple data
scientists
take on separate tasks and work on the
pipeline in parallel
and modular code is also way easier to
test and manage
here on the bottom
we have an example of a cell that plumer
has automatically injected into a
notebook with run parameters and product
paths
so you can see
it's injected
the run type
and the run date and the paths to the
output files have also been dynamically
added
uh notice the output paths have the run
type and run date within the path so
plummer's actually made it really easy
to organize our outputs across different
parameterized runs of the pipeline
this also helps us create our living log
files that data scientists can easily
access for debugging and development
when we save and close the notebook this
temporarily injected cell will
automatically be removed
so these run specific parameters don't
end up saved in our source code
and finally polymer helps us save time
with incremental builds and speeds up
debugging
so bloomer tracks the status of tasks
and if they're up to date or
if they need to be rerun
and this really helps us speed up
development and iteration
as well as debugging and crash recovery
uh so looking
at the plot on the right we have an
example of a plumer dag with different
tasks
outputs and dependencies
and if we introduce a source code change
towards the end of the pipeline
plumer knows it doesn't need to rerun
the whole thing just the end
so this saves us a lot of time if you
have like long running pipeline tasks
you don't have to rerun the whole thing
and then
outputs
plumer also outputs an executed notebook
file for each task so this makes
debugging much easier and more
accessible
the output notebook and artifacts
lets you immediately locate and identify
the failure
interact with the code at that point in
the pipeline
and
makes it really easy to point teammates
to the issue so this tremendously
increases the speed of debugging and
failure recovery
uh plumer helped us solve a lot of our
pipeline orchestration challenges
and we're not able to easily manage our
pipeline with modular jupiter notebook
tasks
but we still needed
a
we still needed to package our pipeline
to make it portable
so
packaging our repo helps us modularize
the utilities that our notebook tasks
rely on
and this makes
them importable from different
directories so this is really necessary
for us because we want to be able to
easily run our output notebooks in
various output artifact directories
without running into
python import issues
we also want to
bring in best practices of software
engineering to our pipeline so this
includes
testing documentation and continuous
integration
as i mentioned before
setting up this code base can get pretty
complicated and usually means we lose
our notebooks so this is where envy dev
comes into play
so envy is a library developed by fastai
that allows you to develop
a python library in jupyter notebooks
putting
all of your code tests and documentation
in one place
with mbdev
we're able to develop directly with
jupiter notebooks which allows us to
explore and iterate rapidly
source code tests and docs
are all kept in one accessible location
uh mbdev automatically creates python
modules from jupiter notebooks and
supports two-way sync so you can edit
the modules directly
use
whichever id
you feel most comfortable with
it also automatically creates searchable
hyperlink documentation from your code
it automatically sets up continuous
integration so you can automatically run
tests in parallel
and build docs on push to github
and
finally it handles conflicts uh makes
version controlling and code reviewing
notebooks really easy
so here we have a testimony in the wild
from a data scientist that was
onboarding to this project
and they were just so impressed by how
easy nbw was making development with
jupiter notebooks
and then on this slide we have an
overview of
uh what using mbdev looks like so
we have the jupiter notebook
in the top left and this is where we
have our source code examples tests and
dots
these notebooks really let you tell a
story with the code you're developing
and let you keep all this useful content
in in one central place
nbdev then converts this notebook into a
python module and automatically sets up
the ci to make sure that your package is
building correctly
uh it's running the tests that you
defined in your notebooks since doing
that in parallel
and it creates the html pages for your
docs
so on the
right side we have an example of one of
these html pages
and
you can see it's automatically
created organized and searchable
documentation
complete with a table of contents
api references
for your source code
examples and tests that you had defined
in your notebook
docs strings and explanations
and even links to source code
uh so here's another example of a page
that's been automatically generated
by nbdev from a jupiter notebook
this page serves as the readme for the
repo
so new
contributors can quickly get up to speed
by looking through the documentation on
how to contribute
uh they can get an overview of the repo
and what the different files and
directories are for
they can see an automatically generated
plot of the plumer dag
outlining all the tasks in the pipeline
and since this is all a jupiter notebook
behind the scenes it's really trivial to
add things like plots or images or mark
down to your documentation
and so now that setting up documentation
is so easy
we can more easily ensure that our docs
are up to date and
really make it easy for our data
scientists to onboard to new
projects
so what are the key takeaways that i
hope you'll take away from this talk
jupiter is a production ready platform
with mbdev and plumer we developed a
workflow that allows us to produce
maintainable robust production-ready
machine learning pipelines directly from
jupiter
and this flu season we're doing it again
so we're running
uh we're currently running in production
to send personalized daily flu
predictions to hundreds of thousands of
achievement members
and this was really enabled with plumer
and mb devs plumer which allows us to
develop and orchestrate our pipelines
and lets us rapidly iterate explore and
develop with jupiter notebooks it
enables modularization so we can easily
break up pipelines into separate tasks
and it saves time with incremental
builds and speeds up debugging
and then
we're able to create python
projects with nbdev
so we can develop software with jupyter
notebooks we can keep all of our source
code tests and docs in one place
and it automatically sets up testing
building docs and ci for us
so here are some resources you may find
useful um the
developers of bloomer and nbdev have
great tutorials
uh blog posts and documentation on their
websites
if you're interested in learning more
about these tools i highly recommend
checking those out
and
if you're interested in learning more
about the work and research we do at
edition please feel free to reach out
and check out our website
um so thanks so much for having me and
happy to take any questions
all right thank you very much i really
appreciate
this
talk philip so i'm going to review
i think
eduardo blancas is mentioning this is an
amazing talk
i'm also reviewing our question and
answers panel
well for our participants does anybody
have any question
all right thanks a lot
dan we have one question from dan
and he's asking asking are users of are
able to contribute to the in development
work
yeah so um
the
this is a new workflow and it's um been
used with a lot of success with our
python users um
the plumer does support uh r
um
but it hasn't been tested so i'm not
sure if there's uh any
um
yeah any like edge cases where it
doesn't work uh with r uh but it's
something that we'll definitely be uh
exploring in the near future
that's
all right philip
well there's another comment from dilip
who says this was a nice talk thank you
very much philip thanks also for the
library's references
yeah definitely i'm glad to help
so that's it philip i want to thank you
very much for your time and your
wonderful presentation i think it's
quite interesting knowing about new
resource resources such as
bloomberg
bloomberg yeah
so i'm going to stop the report
recording and we are going to get ready
for our next session which is going to
begin in just a few minutes
thanks so much for having me